I know this is hard but I need to ask
you some questions about what happened
he tied my hands
he said if I screamed he'd kill me no
signs of forced entry doors and windows
were locked no DNA not a single neighbor
saw or heard a thing
he brought a blindfold but nothing to
tie her with would a shoelace even hold
her
you think Murray made up the attack I'm
pretty positive that it happened pretty
positive or positive they just kept
asking me the same question how come
your story doesn't add up
I wanted to go home I don't have a
victim here it's bogus
she made it up we're on the scene of a
violent attack police say a masked
assailant broke in while the victim was
sleeping he said you need to be more
protective of yourself
black mask bindings early-morning
attacks I think he's done this before
Aurora 18 months ago intruder
black mask backpack tighter I took
photos to date has not been caught you
see the pattern there's a rape new
evidence new leads and then one by one
they dry up until he hits again this one
they're figuring out on our own what if
he knows stations don't talk to each
other as long as he only hits once in
each town and you could have detectives
from eight different departments
investigating eight identical ribs with
no crew they're all chasing the same guy
victims are all over the map old young
different races so he doesn't have a
tight cheer he does woman he'll live a
lot
guy is out there preying on the most
vulnerable women he can find where is
the outrage
this is not something people get over
this is something they carry with them
forever
[Music]
even with people that you can trust if
the truth is inconvenient
they don't believe it
you
you